les jetons calif
arrêt à l'immigration et priorité à
l'intégration des étrangers déjà
installés en france
le gouvernement durcit sa politique et
met en place un nouveau dispositif le
régime est-allemand à la dérive le
numéro à egon krenz démissionne de
toutes ses fonctions rencontre
mitterrand gorbatchev à kiev en ukraine
à l'ordre du jour les bouleversements en
europe
polémique à l'assemblée nationale après
les incidents d'hier soir opposant les
forces de l'ordre à des défis ces
manifestants pour le liban madame
monsieur bonsoir
il aura tenu six semaines six semaines
avant d'être inspiré à son tour par le
tourbillon qui détruit le régime est
allemand egon krenz qui avait succédé à
eric hanna caire fin octobre egon krenz
a démissionné de toutes ses fonctions et
le congrès extraordinaire du parti qui
devait avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
s'ouvrira dès vendredi soir le vide du
pouvoir se creusent en allemagne de
l'est
quand une partie le sourire des cônes
krenz n'aura pas suffi pour les east
allemand egon krenz est un dur du régime
il ne pouvait convaincre dans son récent
de réformateurs pendant des années il a
été celui qui a la tête de la police à
museler l'opposition homme d'appareil
il a grandi dans l'ombre de l'ancien
numéro un est riche n'écoeure ça le
peuple ne peut lui pardonner mais son
départ aujourd'hui marque - le début
d'une ère de réformes qu une étape
supplémentaire dans la désagrégation de
l'état est-allemand
sous la pression du peuple en quelques
jours
presque tout ce qui restait de
l'institution socialiste a sombré le
comité central le bureau politique du
parti
la direction de la police et des
services de renseignement en
démissionner les anciens dirigeants sont
arrêtés ou en fuite
aujourd'hui manfred gerlach
non-communiste succède à egon krenz la
présidence du conseil d'état mais de
fait le pouvoir et laisser vacant en
quelques semaines tous les tabous du
régime communiste en sauter malgré
certains heures un seul reste intacte
pour l'instant la présence des troupes
soviétiques sur le territoire
est-allemand vélo régime ou ce qu'il en
reste ne peut que continuer à lâcher du
lest en amnistiant par exemple certains
délits de droit commun
jérôme baugnies et roger mode se
trouvait à berlin est dans une prison de
femmes au moment où l'avenir ce qui a
été annoncé
explosion de joie dans les cellules de
cette prison de femmes de que pernac
dans la banlieue de berlin est
les détenus purgent des peines de courte
durée elles viennent d'apprendre
l'amnestie des petits délits une
amnistie qu'elle réclamait depuis plus
d'un mois
ah oui
la visite de cette prison modèle avait
commencé une heure auparavant le
directeur nous affirmant qu'il n'y avait
pas de détenus politiques
dans cet établissement les détenus ils
sont employés dans sept blanchisserie
l'avant 35 tonnes de linge par jour
nos contacts avec elles nous font
toucher du doigt le flou de la frontière
entre détenus politiques et de droit
commun
suite au comportement asocial ça veut
dire que je n'y suis pas allée au
travail
moi j'ai deux conductrices de tomber
mais déjà pendant l'apprentissage il y a
eu des problèmes j'aurais dû changer de
brigade
finalement j'ai dû nettoyer des tramways
ça ne me plaisait pas j'ai commencé à
boire de nombreuses autres détenus sont
comme catherine condamnés en vertu de
l'article 249 du code pénal est allemand
pour comportement asocial par exemple si
mona qui refusait aussi de travailler
j'étais femme de ménage est impossible
de changer d'emploi j'ai refusé d'aller
au travail
mais ce soir dans l'euphorie de
l'amnesty tout cela est oublié
j'ai décidé moi j'ai commencé tout de
suite après nous avons tout crié de joie
je suis si heureuse la chasse à la
corruption en allemagne de l'est et la
délation entretiennent la colère d'une
population qui veut maintenant la peau
des anciens profiteurs des anciens
dirigeants
le reportage de philippe rochot et
herbet reading une route de campagne
sans indication à peine surveiller c'est
là que le président du conseil d'état et
secrétaire général du parti et riche en
équerre aujourd'hui en résidence
surveillée
venait passer ses vacances et ses
week-ends cette date ch à 180 km au nord
de berlin est a été placé sous la
protection des mouvements d'opposition
nouveau forum et du procureur de la
république
garage pour 20 voitures piscine sauna et
paraboles pour capter toutes les
émissions des télévisions occidentales
au necker il a été vu pour la dernière
fois en août cette année c'est là qu'il
pratiquait la chasse et la pêche
c'est dégoûtant ce qu'on apprend
maintenant sur ces gens là vous aviez
déjà parlé avec lui le grand jeu le
saluer comme ça de loin mais parler avec
lui n'ont jamais directement
on le voyait comme ça on était il
faisait du vélo on a bien fait de le
mettre en prison
vous pensez qu'il a détourné beaucoup
d'argent un peu trop au oui de ce film
nous il faut bien qu'on continue de
travailler pour manger et boire mais ces
gens-là nous ont complètement trompé
villa d autres cadres du parti qui
sembleraient banal à l'ouest mais qui
choque ici avec toujours ces antennes
permettant de capter les chaînes privées
occidentales des chiens gardait les
abords et le commun des mortels n'avait
pas le droit de s'arrêter ici des
scellés ont été placés sur toutes les
portes des villas on songe à faire de
ces lieux un centre de vacances pour
handicapés mais personne dans le climat
de suspicion actuelle ne se risque à
décider de l'avenir des résidences de la
nomenklatura en tchécoslovaquie le parti
communiste continue de perdre du terrain
face à l'opposition le premier ministre
adamek doit présenter d'ici la fin de la
semaine un nouveau gouvernement fédéral
remaniée avec l'aval de l'opposition
c'est ce qu'a annoncé son chef de file
vacaf havel qui a rencontré pour la
première fois ce matin le chef du parti
communiste le président mitterrand qui
est aussi le président en exercice de la
communauté européenne a passé quelques
heures à pieve en ukraine aujourd'hui
pour s'entretenir de l'évolution de
l'europe avec le numéro un soviétique
mikhaïl gorbatchev sur place gilles
leclerc et yves parent
une surprise attendait françois
mitterrand à l'aéroport de kiev mikhaïl
gorbatchev venu lui-même l'accueillir à
sa descente d'avion
ce n'était pas prévu au programme ce
sera un geste noter parmi d'autres c'est
d'après midi de la part du numéro un
soviétique décidément plein d'égards
vis-à-vis du président français une
visite éclair de quelques heures dans la
capitale ukrainienne pour la sixième
rencontre entre les deux hommes
deux hommes qui ont tout de même eu le
temps de s'attarder lors de la visite de
la cathédrale sainte-sophie églises
byzantines du 11e siècle transformée en
musée en tout cas pas d'ordre du jour
imposée pour les discussions qui ont
bien sûr tourné autour du récent sommet
de malte des changements à l'est du
problème allemand et de l'aide
économique de l'ouest à l'est des
changements à l'aise que michael
gorbatchev approuvent et souhaite
accompagner mais dans la stabilité des
alliances si évolution il y a dit il
elle doit se faire par étapes
par exemple pour l'éventuel problème de
la réunification allemande
c'est aussi la philosophie exprimés il y
a un instant par françois mitterrand qui
souhaite lui ne pas inverser les
priorités qu'un de nos b en europe
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de pays dont le
poids aussi lourd dans la situation
géographique et elle aucun pays en
europe ne peut se dispenser d'agir sans
tenir compte de l'équilibré au pays sans
tenir compte des autres sans tenir
compte de la situation historique du
moment celle qui résulte de la dernière
guerre mondiale
aussi me répond c'est elle que il
convient de ne pas inverser l'ordre des
facteurs
et en particulier ne pas commencer par
poser le problème des frontières
un discours bien compris par mikhaïl
gorbatchev qui souhaite d'ailleurs ne
plus donner de caractère extraordinaire
de telles rencontres
un signe là aussi du rapprochement vous
aurez remarqué que monsieur mitterrand
porte fort bien l'achat pas qu'il avait
d'abord mise à l'envers
comme il est de tradition avant le
sommet européen qui commencera à
vendredi à strasbourg
monsieur mitterrand a écrit aux
partenaires européens pour les
convaincre d'accélérer l'union
européenne mais il semble bien que la
france et l'allemagne fédérale ne soit
pas d'accord sur la convocation d'une
autre conférence sur l'union monétaire
la situation économique de la france ne
lui permet plus d'être une terre
d'immigration tel est le constat qui
oriente désormais la politique du
gouvernement sur un terrain dont on a
vérifié au cours des dernières semaines
l'importance et les difficultés la
priorité devient double mieux contrôler
les entrées et mieux assurer
l'intégration des étrangers déjà
installés en france
un comité interministériel est mise en
place à nice poirier réduire
l'immigration clandestine ce sera
l'ordre du jour de la première réunion
de ce comité interministériel 19
décembre prochain et services de l'ofpra
l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et apatrides vont être
renforcées et modernisé objectif réduire
à six mois maximum le traitement des
dossiers
actuellement il faut souvent plusieurs
années et durant ce délai nombre de faux
réfugiés s'installent illégalement en
france
la deuxième réunion le 11 janvier
portera sur le logement une volonté
supprimer les ghettos le gouvernement
envisage la fermeture de plusieurs
foyers d'immigrés en même temps les
besoins en logement des familles
d'immigrés devront être mieux évaluer
les orcs mais les associations
d'immigrés seront présentes dans les
commissions l'attribution des hlm et les
rejets de demande hlm devront être
motivées et notifié la troisième réunion
le 31 janvier sera consacré à l'école
pour deux français du soutien cours de
rattrapage les langues d'origine et
l'histoire des principaux pays de
l'immigration dans les programmes
scolaires un impératif intégrer les
enfants 1 sur l immigration du
gouvernement veut que na où les
problèmes se posent en lien avec les
collectivités locales dans un quartier
hlm dans une école il ya une population
un forte d'enfants défavorisés
lorsqu'il y a des problèmes de formation
professionnelle ou d'emploi et bien que
des mesures qui soient ajustés au besoin
puissent être prises puissent être
adaptée
dernier point un conseil de réflexion
constitué de personnalités indépendantes
va suivre de près l'action entreprise
par le gouvernement et remettra son
rapport en avril prochain
les chiffres sont sans appel d'après un
sondage publié cette semaine par paris
match
les deux tiers des français estiment
qu'en matière d'immigration le seuil de
tolérance est maintenant atteint et
large majorité se prononce pour
l'intégration des immigrés même si le
cas des maghrébins leur paraît le plus
difficile à noter aussi dans ce même
sondage que 62% des français sont
inquiets de la progression du front
national
l'intégration des immigrés passe entre
autres par le logement
mais la discrimination dans
l'attribution des hlm au lieu de
faciliter l'insertion la rend souvent
illusoire c'est ce que j'en paye les
frais des baskets ont constaté dans le
quartier de la goutte d'or à paris
l'office hlm de paris rue du cardinal
lemoine monde sait faire part comme
chaque fois sans succès cela fait quatre
ans qu'il y a déposé une demande de
logement mouncef n'est pas un marginal
électricien il a un travail régulier
faute de logement adapté ce tunisien sa
femme et leurs trois enfants s'entassent
dans moins de vingt mètres carrés les
cinq personnes dorment dans la même
champ effet il demande au colonel
lemoine de piquette 4e 26 il a pris moi
ni mon voile envoie une lettre comprend
la commission va voir étudiées monde
aussi mais ça laisse sans réponse
on vit vraiment dans de mauvaises
conditions
surtout comment le grand est la 8 ans et
demi on la garde toujours avec l'ombre
dans la chambre il ya combien de temps
vous êtes en quoi nous et 16 ans c'est
en saison et j'ai jamais habité
malheureusement confortable germé de
leur vie s'ils n'étiez pas tunisien ou
pensiez que les choses en seraient
identiques si je suis pas étranger
peut-être que l'oni les immigrés
pourtant constitue le quart des
locataires hlm une proportion plus
grande que dans le parc privé
le problème c'est qu'on les regroupe
seulement dans quelques sites et avec
comme risque le ghetto
d'où la tentation de certains de ne pas
en accepter davantage il faut en fait
que les immigrés soient traités comme le
saut traiter tous les ans diffuser un
pays pas de quotas pas de quotas
les hlm c'est du logement social
les demis c'est aussi bien l'aide à
celui qui a le smig celui que celui qui
a eu lui font que celui qui a 18 ans et
ce n'est pas que coller des des familles
est lourde
ce n'est pas que l'aide aux immigrés ils
ne peuvent pas porter non plus tous les
trucs l'immigration du monde et tous les
péchés du monde des logements privés
avec une aide financière pour les
propriétaires qui logeront les ménages
modestes dont les immigrés c'est l'objet
d'un projet de loi en discussion au
parlement
son but répartir la charge des familles
fragiles
sur l'ensemble des logements décision
annoncée ce matin en conseil des
ministres plutôt on réactions politiques
qu'elles ont provoquées dans la journée
je pense qu'elle constitua une fuite en
avant de la part d'un gouvernement qui
n'a su ni prévoir ni vouloir comme
d'ailleurs ceux qui l'ont précédé jeu
comme j'analyse et nous analysons que
c'est l' égalitarisme social pratiqué à
l'égard des étrangers qui motive et qui
expliquent l'irruption de deux millions
d'étrangers dans nôtre pays qui ne fait
qu'annoncer d'autres vagues et bien le
développement d'une politique dette
sociale aux immigrés d'insertion sociale
aux immigrés provoquera de nouvelles
vagues d'immigration sans d'ailleurs
réussir une intégration
je vais mesures qui ont été prises il
vend ce qu'il fallait d'abord avant tout
définir la portée et les limites d'une
politique d'intégration cela n'a pas été
fait voeu de temps à intégrer tous les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
commençons par l'analyse critique de ce
qui a été fait jusqu'à maintenant et
notamment les disques
les combats et la rentrée pour les
parties je constate qu'il a fallu 18
mois monsieur rocard pour prendre la
mesure d'une situation de l'immigration
qui date d'il ya cinq ans et pour
décider de mesures tout à fait
partielles qui ne résoudront pas le
problème mais qui sont il faut le
reconnaître déjà interdite un premier
pas réactions auxquelles par véronique
c'est nives à noter aussi la réaction de
la cfdt pas de repli sur soi pour
assurer l'intégration et concertation
avec les organisations concernées pour
la réussir à l'assemblée nationale cet
après midi le nouveau et unique député
du front national madame stirbois a fait
une entrée remarquée flanqué de jean
marie le pen vous voyez et d'autres
anciens députés du front national elle a
été ensuite prendre sa place tout en
haut de l'hémicycle flûte en os et à
l'extrême droite comme il se doit à
l'assemblée une polémique a éclaté cet
après midi entre le ministre de
l'intérieur et les députés de
l'opposition
motif les incidents qui ont opposé hier
soir les forces de l'ordre à des
parlementaires qui manifestaient leur
soutien au général libanais aoun devant
le quai d'orsay
henri philippe de villiers ceint de son
écharpe tricolore ancien secrétaire
d'état à la culture
juché sur les grilles de l'assemblée
nationale une image des plus insolites
il est 20h30 hier quand une quarantaine
d'élus de l'opposition se retrouvent
devant le palais bourbon
l'accès étant bloqués par les forces de
l'ordre il crie alors leur colère plus
d'une demi heure auparavant face à
l'entrée du quai d'orsay
dix d'entre eux avaient été molestés par
les crs parce qu'ils tentaient de
franchir des barrières
ce matin françois léotard président du
parti républicain s'étonner que l'on
fasse un incident d'une péripétie
quant au ministre de l'intérieur bien
que regrettant tout d'abord devant les
députés
cet après midi il fut bien loin de
minimiser la sphère le droit de savoir
que lorsque le ministre des affaires
étrangères reçoit des centaines de
personnalités étrangères dans le palais
du quai d'orsay
il doit pouvoir les recevoir et en même
temps recevoir une délégation de
parlementaires françaises sans qui le
trouble à l'ordre public
une vive polémique à ce propos entre
pierre méhaignerie au nom du groupe udc
et deux membres du gouvernement pierre
joxe et lionel jospin
philippe de villiers l'un des
parlementaires molesté s'en explique
est il normal que dans une démocratie
comme la nôtre
fait inédit dans l'histoire de la
république des parlementaires revenant
pacifiquement d'une manifestation pour
rejoindre leur bureau souhaite ainsi
matraquaient tabassé par les forces de
l'ordre
des crs ont chargé des élus des élus ont
tenté de franchir les portes de leur
assemblée une bien grande effervescence
dont on a fini par oublier la raison une
manifestation de soutien au liban à
l'assemblée encore discussions en
deuxième lecture du projet de loi sur le
financement des partis politiques
pascal guimier didier d'or l'amendement
fantôme est bel et bien en train de se
matérialiser
après deux mois de réflexion et quelques
heures de vrai faux suspense
l'amnistié procédons surface mais une
amnistie qui est partielle en commission
des lois les députés se sont entendus
pour passer l'épongé
mais pour le chef d'entreprise les
intermédiaires pas pour les élus à
l'assemblée
on a cette dignité c'est connu un
amendement en tout cas accepté comme en
catimini
personne ne voulant prendre le risque de
faire le premier pas finalement c'est
jean-pierre michel qui s'est dévoué et
dans l'amendement qui va être je suppose
adopté je l'espère les parlementaires
sont extraites amnistie afin qu'on ne
dise pas que l'assemblée s'auto amnistie
ou s'auto blanchi résultat un compromis
qui semble dire arrange quand même un
peu tout le monde
le rpr lui-même avoue répéter qu'il est
contre l'amnistié la liberté de vote
sera de règles dans l'hémicycle pour lui
il est vrai que nous avons suffisamment
de souplesse sa de notre groupe avec un
certain nombre d'entre nous iront
peut-être à l'abstention tout se jouera
donc en séance de nuit quand
l'amendement sera enfin déposé seuls les
communistes sont irréductiblement contre
en revanche presque tous les socialistes
voteront pour des députés udf se
laisseront certainement fléchir plus une
fraction du rpr et un escadron centriste
glissant vers l'abstention
après les pétitions de principe c'est
donc le retour au pragmatisme le nom
mais des uns ou des autres risque bien
de ressembler cette nuit un oui un oui
peut-être un peu honte
le financement des partis ce sera
précisément le thème tout à l'heure à
22h05 de place publique
le magazine de toutes ses rayons le
premier ministre michel rocard en visite
officielle en yougoslavie il est arrivé
à belgrade tout à l'heure et doit
exprimer le soutien français et
européens aux réformes économiques
entreprises par le régime fédérale
yougoslave
les barons de la drogue ont frappé fort
en colombie aujourd'hui l'explosion d'un
camion piégé devant le quartier général
de la police secrète à bogota a fait au
moins 30 morts et un millier de blessés
dominique verdeilhan un cratère de 30
mètres de diamètre et de 10 mètres de
profondeur
tout autour le même spectacle celui d'un
quartier dévasté par ce nouvel attentat
tout bogota a ressenti le souffle de
l'explosion
très vite un appel à la population a été
lancée pour des dons du sang le dernier
bilan est de plus de 40 morts et d'un
millier laisser les 500 kg de dynamite
été placés dans ce camion en
stationnement devant le quartier général
de la police secrète colombienne où sont
détenus des personnalités liées au
trafic de drogue
cet attentat n'a pas été revendiqué mais
il est sans aucun doute un nouvel
épisode de la guerre déclenchée par le
cartel de medellin contre les autorités
colombiennes
hier c'est un juge chargé de la lutte
anti-drogue qui a été abattu à medellin
au même moment les autorités
colombiennes confirmait que l'explosion
du boeing 727 le 27 novembre dernier
était bien due à une bombe
l'explosif était placé sous un siège
les réservoirs l'attentât qui a fait 111
morts avait été revendiqué par un groupe
terroriste
les extradables lié au cartel de
medellin dans le même temps les
policiers européens marqué un point avec
l'arrestation dans cet hôtel de lugano
en suisse de cinq gros bonnets de la
drogue parmi lesquels ces verrou escobar
en numéro 6 mondial dans la hiérarchie
les trafiquants ne veut de pablo escobar
l'un des chefs du cartel de medellin
les trafiquants traquer en colombie ont
semble-t-il fait de l'europe
la nouvelle plaque tournante de leur
activité d'autres informations en bref
avec anne pour signer est d'abord l'état
d'urgence limitée décrété aux
philippines au sixième jour de la
rebellion corazon aquino décide
d'appliquer l'article 12 de la
constitution
il ne s'agit pas d'une loi martiale mais
l'état prend directement en charge les
entreprises publiques et privées est
essentielle à la vie du pays
aujourd'hui à manille les étrangers
bloqués dans le secteur des combats ont
été libérés sains et saufs et les
négociations continuent entre le
gouvernement et les éléments rebelles de
l'armée
attentat contre la résidence de
l'ambassadeur d'espagne à là et peu de
blessés pas de dégâts en deux mois c'est
le quatrième attentat contre une cible
espagnol aux pays bas les trois premiers
ont été revendiqués par le taa
organisation autonomistes basques
nadia comaneci en floride la gymnaste
roumaine ya rejoint son ami un exilé
roumain qui l'avait aidé à fuir
clandestinement son pays mardi dernier
nadia comaneci n'a pour l'instant aucun
projet sportif aux états unis
polémique autour de la tour de pise pour
un des ministres du gouvernement italien
l'édifice pencher trop dangereux il faut
interdire son accès aux visiteurs la
décision reviendra finalement au maire
de la ville
reprises émaillé de débrayage aux
chantiers de l'atlantique hier la
direction créé la surprise en annonçant
la réouverture des chantiers sans
s'opposer à la reprise les syndicats a
appelé aujourd'hui à poursuivre le
mouvement
selon la direction les débrayages ont
quand même diminué de moitié
demain manifestation à nantes
à la bourse de paris en hausse de 1,08
pour cent de l' indice de référence
appelé 4,40
le dollar s'échange à 6 francs 07 05 au
cours officiel
vous savez que cette année encore à
partir de vendredi antennes de engage
toutes ses forces dans l'opération
téléthon au service de l'association
française contre les myopathies et plus
globalement de la recherche comme
secteur des maladies génétiques
un exemple parmi d'autres hélas la
rétinite pigmentaire c'est une maladie
qui a fait quelques quarante mille
personnes en france petit à petit elles
deviennent aveugles caroline glorion et
joseph page tic ont recueilli le
témoignage de nathalie l'hôte allemand
qui m'a annoncé fragments que ces
maladies qui se délient pas que qui ne
fait qu on devient aveugle il a fait les
examens et au bout il ya diverses îles
britanniques du notaire pour l'instant
et encore rien à faire et on sait pas
combien de temps mais du coup tu
deviendras tout cela j'ai pu et je
partais pour avoir des lunettes quoi
pour une chance et cette nuit au pays
hôte comme ça et puis en fait c'est
tombé comme ça
il ya quatre ans nathalie apprend
qu'elle est malade
la rétinite pigmentaire est une maladie
génétique et dégénérescente depuis sa
vue baisse chaque jour un peu plus
aujourd'hui elle a 18 ans et poursuit
ses études de kinésithérapeute dans un
centre pour jeunes aveugles dans la
banlieue parisienne
jusqu'à présent on atteint des vies
comme tout le monde mais elle sait que
la maladie gagne tous les jours du
terrain où je fais du vélo je fais je
fais comme mes frères je les suis
partout mais quand tu vois pas ce qu'on
va en montagne on adore la montagne mais
quand ils voient une biche ou une
marmotte au moins bon et criant allez
belle et jolie mary shawa pas y croire a
dit oui à lisa mandel chez nous il ya
des choses comme ça de temps en temps ça
chez nous ça fait mal au mans le fait de
pas conduire le fait de pas pouvoir
faire comme les autres copains moment
j'ai eu du mal à l'accepter mais bon
maintenant si elle plonge la passe c'est
sûr que tous les matins quand je veux
tous les soirs quand je me couche je
pense qu'un jour peut-être dommage quand
meme je sui du mal
on vit au jour le jour le téléthon
c'était encore fort à vous le savez
appel à votre générosité je vous
conseille vivement la lecture de
l'hebdomadaire la vie la vie de cette
semaine qui est entièrement consacrée au
téléthon numéro à ne pas manquer et puis
cette information encore qui intéresse
les parents des enfants qui doivent
porter des lunettes
elles vont être mieux remboursés par la
sécurité sociale pour les enfants de
moins de 16 ans puisque le forfait passe
de solifor à 450 2 millions de francs
c'est ce que vont devoir payer
l'écrivain régine deforges et les
éditions ramsay aux héritiers de
margaret mitchell
l'auteur de autant en emporte le vent
d'après le tribunal de paris la
bicyclette bleue et il ressemble rétro
mais l'auteur et l'éditeur fonce à peine
allongées au cinéma matin on est
mercredi et allons voir black rain la
pluie noire avec le très séduisant
michael douglas
nicole corps du langlois
un flic yankees au fil de la plume noire
d'hiroshima
ce n'est pas de tout repos les quartiers
chauds de zaka on vous ressemblez aux
bas-fonds de manhattan les habitudes
policiers ne sont pas les mêmes et
michael douglas justicier dur mais pas
toujours plus lent sans m'aperçois doute
à ses dépens michael douglas dans le
film rencontre policiers japonais qui
est l'antithèse de son personnage
c'était quelqu'un qui est guidé par un
cône de morale et donner été extrêmement
forte
on s'était sauvé je bosse quand un
thriller se déroule au sein de la mafia
japonaise le frisson et l' angoisse 140
j'ai horreur valence en fait il
s'inspire d'une réalité que nous
révèlent parfois un document authentique
sur les yakuzas aux mains rétrécit
il coupe le doigt avec un couteau d'un
héros le rôle dans un papier et l'envoie
leur bosse mais ça se passe comme cela
vraiment con vraiment alors j'ai voulu
qu'on le prix c'est dans cet univers
implacable de cowboy et de samouraï des
moments de grâce une chanson et une
amitié virile invasive cette information
de dernière minute encore la police
saisit aujourd'hui à paris 35 kg
d'héroïne 35 kg c'est la prise la plus
importante en france depuis 15 ans trois
trafiquants présumés ont été arrêtés
voilà très vite encore les pronostics de
carre bresse pour le tiercé et quarté de
demain à vincennes ses favoris donc le
12 le 15 le 18 le dise le 4 le 11 le 3
et le vin dans un instant sophie davant
va vous parler du temps de demain
dernier journal vers 23h30 avec en isan
et bien sûr bonsoir à demain 20 heures
ce